we are going to speak to a couple of
other people here let's go to
um tony
from philly tony from philly you're on
the air
hello
hello
can you do i found fine
you sound like you're completely
underwater what are you saying
how about that do i sound better now you
you know now it's perfectly clear yeah
okay
um
what uh well first off hey david how are
you doing i'm doing that thank you thank
you thank you
uh last time i called them we actually
spoke about uh reparations and i was a
little upset because you titled the
video caller uh argues about reparations
and it was more of a discussion and not
an argument but
okay all right we'll we'll investigate
small small potatoes you know sometimes
those uh you know i enjoyed my
discussion with you about it it wasn't
uh there wasn't any real issue that i
had with you labeling it that way just a
little joke all right what's on your
mind today
uh i wanted to
say how
i think what we need to do is really
amend the constitution to get 50 control
of the corporate boards of directors
uh in order to really get control over
this political environment i i think
people need to be in direct control of
the workplace and that's the natural
next step okay let's explore let's
explore what you mean okay
get control of 50 who for who to control
50 percent of boards of directors
an employee board of directors uh uh
pretty much almost like um
like a union except uh they would have
direct uh control 50 direct control so
maybe so half the seats let's talk
through it calmly so we can understand
it half the seats of the corporation's
board of directors would be held by
employees that presumably are not
executives right it's the their workers
yes okay
and
once a company reaches what size would
this start like i'm guessing this
wouldn't apply to like tiny little
businesses
only publicly traded companies or only
publicly traded
or a company that controls uh
uh
way too much of the market share for a
given industry what about like a huge
non-profit with a thousand employees
that's not publicly traded would it
apply to them as well
you know honestly i haven't thought it
out that far
yeah i mean i like this idea this is
when we talk about democratization of
the workplace
outside of the context of me being
not of me not being when i i'm not a
socialist so just saying
the the the workers just automatically
own the company and that's it there's no
more private ownership like i'm not a
socialist so i don't support that but
when we talk about democratization of
the workplace saying that after a
certain level
it is required to have employee
representation on a board that's a great
idea that's exactly the type of thing
that i find interesting so i you know
when you
when you say we need a constitutional
amendment i don't know if it's done
constitutionally corporations are
typically registered at individual
states maybe it's a state by state thing
i don't know the legality of it but i'm
fascinated by the idea i think you're
we're thinking uh we're thinking big
ideas here
okay well thank you for your time i
appreciate it i just wanted to bring it
up to you and see if i could get a
yay or nay out of you my pleasure thank
you so much for the call very much
appreciate it
that's gonna do it for today we took
some great calls we will take calls
again and we will now go to a very short
break and then be back with more of
today's show